كشف تحليل لشبكه سي ان ان ان اسرائيل
اسقطت مئات القنابل التي يصل وزن الواحده
منها الى 2000 رطل على قطاع غزه واستند
تحليل سي ان ان الى صور الاقمار
الاصطناعيه التي تظهر اكثر من 500 حفره
حفره ارتطام يزيد قطر كل منها عن 12 مترا
وذكر تحليل ان القنابل التي تزن الفي رطل
ظهرت اثارها بشكل بارز في محيط مدينه غزه
خلال شهري اكتوبر ونوفمبر
الماضيين من جهتها نقلت نيويورك تايمز عن
متحدث عسكري اسرائيلي قوله ردا على سؤال
بشان استخدام اسرائيل للقنابل الثقيله ان
اولويه اسرائيل هي تدمير حماس وان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ستنظر في وقت لاحق في هذا
النوع من الاسئله واضاف ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يتخذ الاحتياطات الممكنه
للتخفيف من الاضرار التي تلحق بالمدنيين
معنا من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي اهلا بك سيد الفلاحي ما تعليقك
على ما كشفه هذا التحليل لشبكه سي ان
ان نعم مساء الخير لكم ومشاهدي قناه
الجزيره
نعم الغريب بان هذا التحقيق يظهر بعد
ثلاثه اشهر من الحرب يعني هذا التقرير كان
يجب ان يظهر منذ الشهر الاول على ان
اسرائيل تستخدم اسلحه امريكيه لقتل
المدنيين وتدمير المنازل على اهلها اما ان
يخرج الان بعد هذه الخسائر الكبيره التي
وصلت الى اكثر من 20 ال شهيد واكثر من 60
ال جريح وتدمير البنى التحتيه انا اعتقد
بان هذا هو لذر الرمات في العيون على ان
امريكا لا تقبل بمثل هذه الحوادث وبالتالي
هي الان تتكلم وتكشف هذه الحق قائق من
خلال الصحف الامريكيه استخدمت هذه الاسلحه
التي زودتها بها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والتي تراوحت بين انواع متعدده
ام كي 81 82 83 84 بالاضافه الى بلو 109
بالاضافه الى قدوم حسب الانواع
والى جي بي يو ايضا استخدمت الانواع
الثلاثه يعني نتكلم عن اعداد كبيره جدا
وانواع مختلفه من هذه القنابل استخدمت في
عمليه التدمير وبالتالي لا يمكن لنا ان
ياتون اليوم لكي يقولوا بان هذه استخدمت
من قبل اسرائيل ويجب ان على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان تنظر في اعطاء مثل
هذه الاسلحه نعم استخدمتها اسرائيل
وارتكبت جرائم حرب وجرائم اباده جماعيه
علما بان القانون الدولي او ان هذه الحرب
جرت خارج القانون الدولي وخارج منظمات
الامم المتحده الحقوقيه والانسانيه
وبالتالي هذه الجرائم هي جرائم حرب واباده
جماعيه ارتكبها الجيش الصهيوني بمساعده
القوات الامريكيه ام هذا التقرير ليس
الاول من نوعه تقارير عديده تحدثت عن
استخدام اسرائيل لاسلحه لم يسبق استخدامها
ضد المدنيين في حروب سابقه ما اهميه تقرير
كهذا لكن لا يبدو ان اسرائيل تكترث لها
عندما يقول المتحدث العسكري الاسرائيلي
هدفنا الان هو محاربه حماس ثم سنتحدث
لاحقا عن هذه
التقارير
نعم حقيقه هذا الامر يعني كالذي جاء بمريض
وعمل له عمليه ثم قال بعد ذلك نجحت
العمليه ولكن المريض مات يعني يعني يعني
عندما يناقشون هذه التقارير بعد هذا
التدمير وهذا الخراب وهذا القتل ما قيمت
هذه التقارير التي سيناقشون انا اعتقد هذا
الامر يعني حقيقه يعني نستطيع ان نقول هو
ضحك على الشعوب ليس الا يعني والا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لتفتح تحقيق
ان كانت جاده في هذا الامر الان لتسمح
الان باصدار قرار بوقف اطلاق النار لا ان
تساعد اسرائيل على عمليات القتل وتستمر
باستخدام الفيتو ثم بعد ذلك تقول بانها لا
تسمح بقتل المدنيين هذا الكلام لا اعتقد
بانه يعني ينم عن مسؤوليه حقيقيه في مساله
ايقاف جرائم القتل التي يقوم بها الكيان
الصهيوني هذه الجرائم جرائم اباده جماعيه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي شريك فيما
يجري وبالتالي كل هذه الجرائم يجب ان
تحاسب عليها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ويحاسبون عليها القاد الصهاينه الذين
قاموا بارتكاب هذه الج نعم طيب ما عدا قتل
المدنيين باعداد كبيره وتفجير المباني
السكنيه ما الذي حققت هذه القنابل الثقيله
التي استخدمتها اسرائيل في هذه الحرب ما
الذي حققتها على الصعيد
العسكري نعم اذا جينا الى اهداف الحرب
نقول الان ما هي الاهداف التي تحققت من
هذه الحرب الاهداف التي تحققت هو قتل
المدنيين تدمير البنى التحتيه هي تدمير
المنازل وتهجير الناس من بيوتها هذا ما
تحقق اما على المستوى العسكري فاعتقد بان
الخسائر الاسرائيليه هي خسائر كبيره جدا
عندما يتم سحب
كتيبه جدعون من المرقم رقم 13 ذم اللواء
جولاني اذا هناك اشكال حقيقي في هذا الجيش
وهناك خسائر كبيره جدا تكبدها الجيش خلال
الفتره الماضيه لم يحقق من اهداف الحرب
شيء لم يتم اطلاق سراح الاسرى ولم يتم
السيطره على على مدينه غزه كما اد الجيش
في في الاهداف وبالتالي نحن نتكلم عن حرب
مستمره وحرب اباده للمدنيين المتواجدين
يعني عندما الان يقصف يقصف السياج نستطيع
ان نقول المنازل الاماميه لمدينه غزه
باتجاه باتجاه مناطق الغلاف ويقوم بتدمير
جميع هذه المنازل الغايه الرئيسيه هو
تهجير السكان والا لا يوجد فيها احد منذ
اليوم الاول القطعات الصهيونيه تجاوزت هذه
المنطقه بالدخول الى عمق المناطق في وخاصه
في القطاع الشمالي واليوم هي تدخل في في
خان يونس اذا ما الداعي اذا تدمير مثل هذه
هذه المنازل او هذه المناطق الغايه من
عندها هو تهجير الناس من هذه المناطق بعد
ان دمر منازلهم يريد ان يهجرهم من مناطقهم
وبالتالي يستخدم سياسه الارض المحروقه في
التدمير بهذا الاسلوب الهمجي شكرا جزيلا
لك الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي العقيده
ركن حاتم كريم الفلاحي من اسطنبول